first on cbs this morning the nfl says 7
500 health care heroes will be invited
to attend
super bowl 55. this is a live shot right
now from raymond james stadium in tampa
florida where the big game will be
played next month
nfl commissioner roger goodell surprised
medical staff at sarasota memorial
hospital
about an hour from tampa watch if you're
able to explain it
i want to thank you roger invite each
member of your team
the five world of mayor unit to be our
guest
at the super bowl
[Music]
no if about whether they're going to be
able to swing it they're not coming so
here's
here's how it goes each nfl team gets to
pick four health care workers
uh from their hometowns who have been
vaccinated the packers who
are one win away from the super bowl
invited dr michael landrum from green
bay wisconsin and he told me
he is pumped you're going to go to the
super bowl
are you kidding yes yeah
how's that i've been a football fan ever
since i was a kid it's kind of surreal
because while i'm down there i still
know that there will be people up here
in the hospital my colleagues here will
still be
at their bedside taking care of them uh
so
it's it's a little bit uh bittersweet in
that way oh yeah
yeah that's so nice of him to
acknowledge that but everybody would
like him to have a break
everybody including his colleagues
coming from wisconsin he's also a big
fan of the florida weather
yeah and he's looking forward to that so
i'm so excited for all these health care
workers nobody
deserves this more than they do 7 500
health care workers uh an additional 14
500 fans so about 22 000 in raymond
james about a third of the capacity
when and where can we watch the super
bowl right here on
cbs there's sunday february 7th tonight
that is our graphic pbs